frédéric landry professeur de géographie
à l'université paris ouest nanterre la
défense membre associé du centre
d'études de l'inde et de l'asie du sud
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors 300
millions de personnes vaccinées en
l'espace de six mois le défier colossal
avec des infrastructures souvent
insuffisante sur le plan logistique est
ce réalisable selon vous je pense que
c'est réalisable à l'échelle pays
le problème s'il est très grande et très
diverses
il est à craindre certaines régions
particulières et on les systèmes de
soins actuellement sont déjà des fils
dans le passé un peu à côté de ceux de
cet énorme campagne alors l'inde a
choisi de vax et sa population avec deux
vaccins celui d'astra zeneca et un
vaccin locale le coc vaccin action
nationale suisse est qu'à la méfiance de
la population pourquoi
oui parce que autant le le premier basse
et astrazeneca vaccins dont on la france
se met à rêver s'il ya des pénuries en
europe qui soit vivant en inde
autant le deuxième est effectivement
c'est un vaccin 100% incarne produit à
hyderabad et le problème c'est qu'on l'a
été avant que la phase 3 l'essai
clinique se soit achevée donc verdict
c'est une situation d'urgence
d'autres disques parce qu'ils étaient
moins chers
astrazeneca et puis je pense que c'est
une question politique
il s'agit en 1/2 urgence peut-être pas
c'est le père étant donné qu'il n'y a
pas de deuxième vague est temps que la
courbe des cas étaient morts surtout et
c'est vraiment beaucoup réduite
c'est pas tellement une urgence
sanitaire à mon avis c'est le genre
social c'est qu'il importe
pendant que l'un redevienne on retrouve
ça marche habituelle et notamment les
écoles ou parce que rendez vous contre
la faim marche toutes les écoles et
collèges fermés même population
complètement choqués par situation qui
risque d'être pas mal pour des années de
la sonde jeunes définitivement quitté
l'école situation était déjà le père de
son pasteur ian alphabètes voyez les
environs on l'a dit sont méfiants
vis-à-vis du vaccin locales mais en
général ils sont beaucoup à vouloir se
faire vacciner 80 % environ de la
population selon une enquête
internationale qui a été réalisée
récemment c'est beaucoup plus que les
européens
comment le pays pour qu'il gérait le
processus on sait qu environ cent
cinquante mille personnes dans 700
district 1 seront à déployer oui et
l'arrière voilà votre question est
double d'une part ya des réticences de
la population ou au collet dans d'autres
pays sont peut-être marqué ans en inde
avec des facteurs culturels et
politiques spécifiques par exemple la
campagne pour la polio il ya quelques
années avait de gros problèmes parce
qu'on s'était répandu le bruit parmi la
population musulmane
le vaccin en péril les hommes
du coup c'était un moyen pour le
gouvernement indien finances hindou de
réduire la croissance démographique de
la minorité musulmane envoyé quelques
coups ce genre de choses qui s'ajoutent
à des craintes sanitaires que l'on
connaît dans les pays développés après
il ya donc l'eau l'autre problème de la
vie de l'infrastructure du personnel en
qualité du vaccin reste d'une bourde de
deux vaccination c'est parce que jours
non plus facile à obtenir de la part de
la cotisation et donc sa sister que
c'est délicat
lépine un état habitué à astaffort 2
lord énorme campagne moi je pense aux
sanctions de la population qui a lieu
tous les dix ans semble un petit peu
c'est énorme machinerie mise en route
pour gérer personnes le vaccin sera-t-il
véritablement accessible à tous selon
vous il ya une bonne part de 5,5
il sera gratuit donc de ce point de vue
là ce n'est pas tellement un problème
coûts affiché sur jour la dose 1 c'est
tout un problème d'accès physique social
où il ya la réticence pour par exemple
des médecins de hautes castes à
accueillir des patients de basses castes
et vice versa c'est un problème de
transport comment comment aller au
centre de vaccination aussi l'état 10 km
s'il faut prendre un autobus
il y aura un coût même si le vaccin est
gratuit rhin un coût non négligeable
pour les populations les plus pauvres
merci beaucoup en tout cas monsieur
frédéric lundi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je rappelle que cette
professeur de géographie à l'université
paris ouest nanterre la défense et
membre associé du centre d'études de
l'inde et de l'asie du sud